[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
موسكو ترحب بخطه السلام الصينيه وترفض
الحديث عن القرم وضغط امريكي الماني على
كييف للحوار
بعد زياره وزير خارجيه مصر لتركيا انقره
تتحدث عن تسريع تحسين العلاقات مع القاهره
[تصفيق]
اردوغان يعتذر لشعبه عن تاخر الاغاثه بعد
الزلزال المدمر وزلزال اليوم يدمر المزيد
من المباني في الطريق
ومع تصاعد الاحتجاجات في ايران الاطاحه
بقائد قوه الشرطه في بلوشستان للمره
الثانيه في غضون اشهر
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من تطورات
الحرب في اوكرانيا ذكرت صحيفه بيلد
الالمانيه طبعا نقلا عن مصادر في
الحكومهتين الالمانيه والامريكيه نقلت ان
الغرب سيضغط على كييفلي اجبارها على اجراء
محادثات سلام مع موسكو اذا فشلت القوات
الاوكرانيه في تحقيق تقدم كبير بحلول
الخريف الصحيفه ذكرت ان المسؤولين
الامريكيين والاوروبيين يريدون منح
اوكرانيا فرصه لاستعاده المزيد من الاراضي
بحلول الخريف وشن المزيد من الهجمات
المضاده قبل التفاوض مع روسيا اذا فشلت
اوكرانيا قالت الصحيفه الالمانيه ان الغرب
يقدم وعودا بدعم اوكرانيا الى ما لا نهايه
ولكن وراء الكواليس هناك حديث بالفعل عما
وصفته بانذار عسكري
موقف موسكو باتا اكثر مرونه ازاء الخطه
الصينيه ولكن يبدو انه ليس كذلك بالنسبه
لشبه جزيره القرم حيث شددت الرئاسه
الروسيه على ان عوده شبه جزيره القرم الى
اوكرانيا تعد امر مستحيل وانها باتت جزء
لا يتجزا من روسيا قال المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه الروسيه ديمتريبيس كوفيد ان
الظروف غير متوافره لانهاء النزاع في
اوكرانيا سلميا في الوقت الراهن لكنه اشار
الى ان روسيا ستدرس خطه السلام الصينيه
وستحلل تفاصيلها وبشكل دقيق ولن تقبل باي
شروط مسبقه للمفاوضات
عام من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه توسطت
فيه كافه الاطراف الدوليه لوقف الحرب الا
انها لم تنجح لتعرض الصين في ذكرى الاولى
للحرب خططا باثني عشر بندا لاحلال السلام
بين الطرفين الاوكراني والروسي
الكريم وصف المبادره الصينيه بانها تستحق
الاهتمام منتقدا لظروف الراهنه التي تحول
دون تنفيذها
اننا ننظر في خطه اصدقاءنا الصينيين
باهتمام كبير انها عمليه طويله في الوقت
الراهن لا نرى الظروف التي من شانها ان
تضع هذه القضيه على مسار سلمي العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه مستمره
[موسيقى]
رحبت بحذر بالخطه
وضع على بعض البنود وزيلينسكي اكد ان فكره
التوسط حليف روسيا في السلام امر مبشر
من الصواب الاعتقاد بانه اذا كانت هناك
افكار تتوافق بطريقه او باخرى مع احترام
القانون الدولي وسلامه الاراضي فلنعمل مع
الصين في هذه النقطه
كما انه عبر عن رغبته بلقاء نظيره الصيني
لمناقشه العمليات العسكريه والعلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين البلدين
بكين من جانبها لم تعلن عن نيه مشابهه بل
اكدت انها ستكون على تواصل مع جميع
الاطراف لمناقشه خطه السلام المقترحه
مشيره انها علمت برغبه الرئيس الصيني
لكنها لم تعلم كيف سيتم اللقاء
تتخذ الصين موقفا واضحا للغايه وثابتا من
الازمه الاوكرانيه نحن على اتصال مع جميع
الاطراف المعنيه بما في ذلك اوكرانيا
ردود فعل غربيه متفاوته قابلت المبادره
الصينيه بعضها كان مشجعا والاخر كان مشككا
اما في الولايات المتحده فقد شككت
المخابرات والبنتاجون بدور الصين بينما
ترك البيت الابيض الباب مفتوحا حول مساهمه
بكين بالحل لكن الابرز هي تسريبات صحفيه
عن توجه غربي للضغط على كيف للقبول
بالمفاوضات خلال اشهر وعمر العربيه
المزيد معنا من اكياب مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل وايضا تنضم الينا من موسكو مراسله
العربيه كاتيا طعمي اهلا بكما ابدا معك
كاتيا هل اصبح الموقف الروسي واضح كفايه
لنفهم ما الذي تريدوا موسكو من هذا
الاتفاق او لا
مرحبا ميسون موقف روسيا طبعا واضح روسيا
كانت قد اكدت مرارا انها مستعده لعقد
اتفاق او للجلوس لطاوله المحادثات مع
اوكرانيا ولكن في ضوء التزويد المستمر من
قبل واشنطن ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي
لاوكرانيا بسلاح فهذا الشيء مستحيل لان
الغرب هو من يدفع اوكرانيا الى اطاله مده
هذه الحركمه ترى موسكو اليوم قال ديميتري
بيسكوف المتحدث الرسمي باسم ان روسيا تولي
اهتماما كبيرا لهذه للوثيقه السلامه التي
قدمتها الصين ولكن حتى الان لا يوجد اي
بوادر
تشير الى انه بالامكان عقد اي محادثات مع
جانب الاوكراني ولذلك روسيا ستتابع
العمليه العسكريه حتى تحقيق جميع الاهداف
التي وضعتها امامها
على ما ذكرته الصين من انه هناك تواصل مع
الجميع سنعرف ان كانت قادره على الضغط
لتمرير مثل هذه الوثيقه على الاقل بدء
وعوده ربما للمفاوضات تسمحي لها ان انتقل
الى حذيفه لنفهم الموقف الاوكراني ماذا عن
هذا الموقف وهل هناك ميل بالفعل لهذه
الوثيقه او انه الموضوع لا الاهميه والعين
على لقاء الرئيس الصيني
مساء الخير في الحقيقه يعني كيف بشكل حذر
انتقدت هذه المبادره على الرغم من حديث
الرئيس في بعض النقاط الايجابي حول هذه
المبادره وهو في الحقيقه لم يصفها
بالمبادره ولكن بشكل واضح قال ان انه يبدو
ان الصين عبرت عن ارائها بشان الحرب ولكن
ايضا عاد واشار وقال بما ان الصين هنالك
بند يتحدث عن احترام سياده الاراضي وسلامه
الاراضي فيجب ان نواصل العمل مع الصين في
هذا الاتجاه ولكنه ايضا بعد ذلك عاد وقال
ان لم يكن هنالك بند واضح بشان انسحاب
الاتحاد الروسي من الاراضي الاوكرانيه في
ذات الاتجاه ذهب جميع المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين ابتداء من القائمه باعمال كيف
في بكين زانا والتي انتقدت الاتفاقيه اولا
هي قالت ان الصين لم تتشاور مع كيف قبل ان
تنشرها هذا اولا ثم ايضا اقاله انه يجب
على بكين ان تعمل كل ما في وسعها يعني
عمليه
استعاده الاراضي الاوكرانيه وسلامه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وفق ما تقول المبادره
ولكن ايضا قائد فصيل خادم الشعب وهو حزب
الرئيس انتقد بشده هذه المبادره وقال ان
الصينيين يقولون انهم هنالك بنت اساسي حول
احترام سياده وسلامه الاراضي ولكنهم لم
يكتبوا بندا واحدا بشان انسحاب الاتحاد
الروسي من الاراضي الاوكرانيه اما الاكثر
يعني اللهجه الاكثر انتقادا كانت لهذه
المبادره كان ميخائيل بودراك وهو مستشار
رئيس الذي ذهب وقال انه اي حديث عن اعاده
ترسيم الحدود او بدء مفاوضات والاتحاد
الروسي داخل اراضينا هذا امر مرفوض تماما
وهو تجميد للحرف وهو عباره عن هزيمه
لاوكرانيا لذلك لن يكون مقبول تماما من
الجانب الاخرى لكن رغم هذه الانتقادات كان
هناك توجه وانفتاح للقاء الرئيس الصيني من
قبل الرئيس الاوكراني وهنا انتقل الى
كاتيا الرئيس الاوكراني كان واضح انه حليف
روسيا يدخل بالوساطه هذا شيء مبشر نريد ان
نجلب الجميع الينا وعدو واحد هل تتخوف
موسكو من استماله الصين الى اوكرانيا
بطريقه او باخرى
حقيقه ميسون من الزياره الاخيره التي قام
بها الدبلوماسي الصيني الى موسكو ومن
الزياره المرتقبه للرئيس الصيني التي
تترقبها موسكو في شهر ابريل المقبل حتى
الان وتصريحات وزير خارجيه خلال لقائه هذا
الدبلوماسي بان العلاقات الصينيه الروسيه
هي متينه جدا ويثبت ذلك التبادل التجاري
كما تحدث ايضا الرئيس بوتين الذي هو في
ازدياد مع الجانب الصيني وان لا شيء يمكن
ان يهز هذه العلاقات فبالتالي لا اعتقد ان
لا يعتقد الخبراء ان هناك توجه لخوف من
قبل ان يتم استماره الصين الى الجانب
الاوكراني الصينيه فقط تقوم بدور
وساطه من خلال هذه الوثيقه التي قامت
بتقديمها ولكن موسكو اليوم قالت ان هذه
البنود بحاجه الى تحليل ودراسه كبيرين من
قبل الجانب الروسي قبيل في حال كان هناك
مبادره من الجانب الاوكراني لقبول هذه
الوثيقه والجلوس الى طاوله المحادثات من
خوف روسي لاستماله اوكرانيا الصين ولكن
ماذا عن اكياب عادل بالفعل تعول على
امكانيه ان تستميل الصين هل يمكن ان
تستخدم الصين كورقه امام ما يسار اعلاميا
على الاقل من انه هناك ضغوط عليها كي تبدا
المفاوضات مع روسيا
نعم في الحقيقه هذا هدف استراتيجي الان
بالنسبه للخارجيه الاوكرانيه هو عمليه
التواصل مع الجميع مع عدا الاتحاد الروسي
وبما في ذلك الصين الحليفه الاستراتيجي
لاموسكو والحليفه القوي لموسكو وعلى الاقل
الان الهدف الاستراتيجي هو اذا لم تستطيع
طبعا هذا امر يعني اذا نظرنا بشكل موضوعي
هو صعب جدا بحيث انه هنالك معسكر الغربي
والمعسكر الصيني
فاذا كان الامر غير موضوعي ولكن على الاقل
ان تجر بكين الى الحياد والا ان تكون وسيط
بدلا ان تكون في المعسكر الاخر وبدل ان
تزود الاتحاد الروسي تعلمين ان هناك حديث
عن تزويد موسكو بالسلاح الصيني وهذا الامر
هدف استراتيجي الان هو منع القدر على
الاقل
نعم هذا نعم بالضبط ولذلك تعمل الان
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه على العمل مع
الصين
جر الصين عن الاعلى وضع الصين على الاقل
في الحياد وايضا زميلتي عندما تحدث عن
اللقاء مع الرئيس الصيني قال ان بعيدا عن
الحرب لدينا يعني التجاره مشتركه لدينا
علاقات اقتصاديه قويه جدا لدينا تبادل
تجاري كبير جدا لذلك انا ارغب بشكل مباشر
في لقائه واجرام مباحثات معه كيف مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل شكرا لك ومن موسكو
مراسله العربيه كاتيا شكرا جزيلا لك
ميدانيا اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
استمرار تكبد القوات الاوكرانيه خسائر في
محاور دونيتسكو
وخرسون
وكراسيليمان وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره في
البيان اليومي ان القوات الروسيه دمرت
مركزا للاستخبارات الالكترونيه هو تابع
للجيش الاوكراني وذلك في مقاطعه كييف كما
دمرت مستودع ذخيره تابع للقوات الاوكرانيه
في مقاطعه موقع لايف
في هذه الاثناء قال الرئيس البيلاروسي
الكسندر لوكاشنك وقال ان بلاده هو
بالشراكه مع روسيا قادره على تصنيع ما
تحتاجه من اسلحه رغم العقوبات الغربيه
نتابع
اود الاشاره الى انه على الرغم من ضغوط
العقوبات غير المسبوقه فاننا ننتج اسلحه
ومعدات عسكريه كافيه لاحتياجات الجيش
البيلاروسي ويرجع ذلك الى ان كل ما نحتاجه
من الاسلحه والحديد نحصل عليه بسهوله من
روسيا فيما يتعلق بالالكترونيات الدقيقه
والالكترونيات الضوئيه والبصريات وغيرها
فالفضل لاولئك الذين حافظوا على مرافق
الانتاج الموروثه من الاتحاد السوفيتي حيث
بامكاننا مع روسيا انتاج اي نوع من
الاسلحه
يبدو ان الاوضاع في مدينه باخمه لا تسير
كما يريدها الجانب الاوكراني حيث اكدت
سلطات دونيتسكا الانفصاليه
قوات بادنار تقاتل في وسط المدينه ما يشير
الى تقدم لافت كان صعبا على مدار اشهر فهل
بدات معركه الربيع التي توقعها الغرب
مبكرا صعوبه الاوضاع على الارض في بخموت
تؤكدها زياره قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه الجنرال الكسندر سيرسكي مطلع
هذا الاسبوع كيف قالت ان الزياره هي لرفع
الروح المعنويه للجنود ولاجراء محادثات
استراتيجيه مع الوحدات التي تدافع عن
البلده والقرى المحيطه في الشرق يتوقع
محللون عسكريون ان تبذل القوات الاوكرانيه
اقصى جهدها خلال الايام المقبله للدفاع عن
باخموت في الوقت الذي جعلت روسيا من
الاستيلاء على المدينه اولويه في
استراتيجيتها للسيطره على منطقه دوم باس
الصناعيه روسيا احرزت تقدما في الاونه
الاخيره نحو تطبيق باخموت حيث لم يبقى سوى
حوالي 5000 من اصل 70 الف من سكانها
الرئيسكي من جانبه يامل ان يقرر عقائده
سرسكي ضد صد الهجمات الروسيه في باخمت حيث
ينظر اليه وهو احد اكثر القاده
الاوكرانيين خبره ينظر اليه بانه العقل
المدبر لهزيمه القوات الروسيه اثناء
تقدمها في كييف خلال وقت مبكر من الحرب
وفي منطقه خارقييف في سبتمبر الماضيه
الجنرال ادوارد موسكاليف لواء في القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه شارك ميدانيا لصد
الهجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا قادم مجموعه
القوات العملياتيه والاستراتيجيه في
اوديسا النائب الاول لقائد قوات قياده
العمليات العسكريه شرق اوكرانيا تم تعيينه
قائدا للقوات المشتركه في الخامس عشر من
مارس لعام 2022
منحه الرئيس الاوكراني وسامه بوجدان خامله
سكي من الدرجه الثانيه اقاله الرئيس
الاوكراني من منصبه بموجب مرسوم رئاسي
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
تويتر تسرح 10% من قوتها العامله ومن
بينهم
مديره انتاج وخبراء في مجال البيانات
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل من
العلاقات بين القاهره وانقر حيث تحدثت
مصادر مصريه للعربيه يتحدث عن ان القاهره
تجهز لي زياره مرتقبه للرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان الى مصر في النصف الثاني من
العام كما اشارت المصادر المصريه الى انه
تم تحديد مباحثات بين مصر وتركيا في شهر
ابريل المقبل لرفع التمثيل الدبلوماسي بين
القاهره وانقره
هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاوش
لو انه من المحتمل ان يعقد اجتماع بين
الرئيسين التركي رجب طيب اردوغان والمصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي خلال الفتره القادمه
واثناء لقاء مع نظيره المصري سامح شكري في
ميناء مرسين اكد الوزير التركي اكد ان
انقره ستعمل على نقل العلاقات مع القاهره
الى مستوى اعلى
نقوم بفتح صفحات جديده مع مصر وسنعمل على
نقل العلاقات مع القاهره الى مستوى اعلى
في الاونه الاخيره كانت هناك مباحثات بين
الرئيس اردوغان والرئيس السيسي وتباحثت
اليوم مع سامح شكري بشان الخطوات التي
علينا اتخاذها لتطوير العلاقات بين بلدين
وتطور العلاقات التركيه المصريه سيؤثر
ايجابا على المنطقه باكملها
المحمل برساله
تضامن مؤازره ومواساه الى الشعب التركي
الصديق
على مستوى القياده
والحكومه والشعب المصري
لهذا المصاب وهذه الكارثه التي تالمنا
جميعا
لوقعها
نعمل بكل ما لدينا من جهد لمؤازره اخواتنا
واخواتنا في
تركيا
لتجاوز هذه المحنه
المزيد معنا من القاهره البحث في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
دكتور بشير عبد الفتاح اهلا بك دكتور بشير
نبدا بالمعلومات المتداوله نقلا عن مصادر
للعربيه زياره لوزير الخارجيه التركي
مرتقبه الى مصر زياره للرئيس التركي الى
مصر وايضا طبعا نحن نعلم سامح شكري ذهب
الى تركيا
برساله تضامن اضافه الى اتصالات سابقه
ومساعدات مصريه هذا كله
فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات المصريه التركيه
حركها الزلزال ام ان الضوابط التي دائما
ما تحرك مصر بهذا الاطار قد تغيرت
تحيه لك يا استاذه ميسون ولكل مشاهدي قناه
العربيه في كل مكان يمكن القول ان
العاملين معا تضافرا للوصول الى هذه
النتيجه بمعنى ان التطور في التقارب
المصري والتركي كان قد بدا منذ العام 2021
بمستوى السفراء وصولا الى مساعدي وزراء
الخارجيه ثم وزراء الخارجيه الان ولم
يتبقى سوى دبلوماسيه القمه ورؤساء الدول
كان الامر سيتطلب ربما بعض اشهر حتى نصل
الى لقاء الرؤساء لكن جاءت كارثه الزلزال
المدمر في السادس من فبراير الحالي وعجلت
من فرص لقاء وزيري الخارجيه ثم رئيسي
الدولتين خصوصا بعد تصافح الرئيسين السيسي
واردوغان في نوفمبر الماضي في الدوحه على
هامش افتتاح مونديال كاس العالم لكره
القدم باختصار
خطوات كانت تمشي بشكل كانت تمضي بشكل
متدرج نحو التقارب ومزيد من التقارب لكن
جاءت كارثه الزلزال وعجلت من هذا التقارب
واحتزلت الزمن والمسافات للتعجيل بهذا
اللقاء هل ستختزل ايضا تطبيق ما تطالب به
مصر خاصه فيما يتعلق بالاخوان او لا
ملف الاخوان المسلمين تراجع الى المرتبه
الرابعه في ملف القضايا الخلفيه الشائكه
بين مصر وتركيا منذ اشهر مضت الملف الاول
هو الملف الليبي الثاني شرط المتوسط
الثالث التدخلات التركيه في سوريا والعراق
وتعطيش الدولتين من خلال المياه ثم الملف
الرابع هو ملف الاخوان المسلمين تراجع ملف
الاخوان المسلمين جاء لسببين رئيسيين
اولهما التصدع الذي ضرب جنبات الجماعه
الارهابيه وباتت يعني في صدام وفي صراع
داخلي افقدها قدرتها على التاثير الامر
الثاني تهافت الدول الغربيه ودول حول
العالم وفي امريكا اللاتينيه وافريقيا
لتصنيف الجماعه كجماعه ارهابيه او لتقييد
نشاطاتها بطريقه او باخرى الامر الثالث ان
تركيا يتعاونت مع مصر وابدت خطوات ايجابيه
من خلال اما توقيف بعض عناصر الاخوان
لديها او بترحيلهم الى خارج تركيا واغلاق
المنصات الاعلاميه
الجماعه داخل تركيا كل هذا ادى الى تراجع
هذا الملف
وتمضي تركيا قدما في طريق اتخاذ خطوات
مرضيه للقاهره بهذا الصدد من خلال وقف
الرهان على جماعه الاخوان كورقه يمكن ان
تستثمرها تركيا في العلاقات مع مصر تبقى
النقاط الثلاثه الاولى بمعنى اخر كونك
ذكرت انه بالمرتبه الرابعه اصبح هذا الملف
ولكن نتحدث في الايام القادمه ونتابع هذه
التطورات من القاهره الباحث في مركز
الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
الدكتور بشير عبد الفتاح شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
وفي تطورات الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
طلب الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
الصفح من شعبه بسبب الاستجابه المتاخره
لكارثه الزلزال في البلاد جاء ذلك خلال
تفقده ولايه اديمان وهي احدى الولايات
المتضرره نتابع
بعد الزلزال المدمر كان هناك طقس بارد
وصعب جدا في الايام الاولى ربما لم نتمكن
من العمل كما كان يلزم بسبب صعوبه الظروف
لذلك اتمنى منكم المسامحه ونحن الان على
يقين باننا سنقوم بكل ما يلزم من اجل
مواجهه هذه التحديات
في هذه الاثناء لم تتوقف الهزات
الارتداديه منذ ما يقرب من شهر على
الزلزال حيث اعلنت اداره الكوارث التركيه
في بيان الله اليوم عن رصد زلزال بقوه
5.6 درجات ضرب مناطق شرق تركيا ما ادى الى
مقتل شخص واصابات عده جراء انهيار مباني
في ملاطيا واوضحت الاداره ان الزلزال كان
مركزه مقاطعه ملاطيا وعلى عمق سبعه
كيلومترات وقد رصدت الاف الهزات
الارتداديه رصدت عاقبه زلزال السادس من
فبراير الماضي
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا تبعات الزلزال المدمر في
تركيا يمتدت الى الجاره اليونان والتي
تتخوف من مرحله ما بعد الكارثه اليونان
تتخوف تحديدا من موجات جديده من اللجوء
اليها ومن ثم القاره العجوز وبالتالي بدات
ادسنه تتحرك سريعا حيث اعلنت عن تعزيز
اجراءاتها الامنيه واللوجستيه على طول
حدودها البريه والبحريه مع تركيا بحسب
صحيفه الجارديان فقد عززت السلطات في اثنا
من قوات حرس الحدود بمئات العناصر
الاضافيه كثفت من دورياتها على طول الحدود
البريه مع تركيا اثنا تتوقع حدوث موجه
هجره جماعيه لكثير من الاشخاص الذين ليس
لديهم ماوى بسبب الزلزال المدمر في تركيا
وسوريا والذي اودى كما نعرف بحياه اكثر من
50,000 قتيل من المقرر ان تتضاعف مساحه
السياج الذي طوله 22 ميلا يبلغ ارتفاعه
خمسه امتار بحلول نهايه هذا العام قبل
الزلزال بلغ عدد الاتراك الذين وصلوا الى
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي بطريقه غير مشروعه
وصل الى
8,600 شخص بالتحديد خلال النصف الاول من
العام الماضي 20 22 التوقعات تشير الى ان
هذا الرقم اقل بكثير من الحقيقه فهو لا
يشمل حامل الجنسيه التركيه والذين وصلوا
الى اوروبا وبتاشيرات سفر ومتى فيها رغم
انتهاء صلاحيات تاشيراتهم وفي اشاره الى
موقف الكتله المتشدده تجاه اللاجئين قالت
حكومه يمين الوسط اليونانيه قالت انها
ستشتري عشرات السفن الجديده لخفر السواحل
طبعا للقيام بدوريات في جزر بحر ايجه
المواجهه للساحل التركي على كل وفي تعليقه
على موجه الهجره هذه المحتمله قال وزير
الهجره اليونانيه قال ان الحركه الجماعيه
لملايين الاشخاص ليس حلا مشد على الحاجه
لارسال مساعده طارئه الى تركيا وسوريا قبل
حدوث ذلك وخلال مؤتمر الاتحاد الاوروبي
لمراقبه الحدود الذي عقد في اثينا الاسبوع
الماضي دعا الى تعزيز حمايه حدود القاره
الاوروبيه تعهد الوزير اليوناني باي يستمر
توسيع سياج مثير طبعا هو للجدل على طول
الحدود البريه مع تركيا بغض النظر عما اذا
كان الاتحاد الاوروبي سوف يموله ام لا قال
انه سيتم تمديد السياج على طول نهر ادرس
بالكامل وذلك لحمايه القاره الاوروبيه من
التدفقات غير القانونيه حسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا تحدثنا عن هجره متوقعه بعد
الزلزال وحول زلزال اليوم معنا من بلده
كرخان على الحدود التركيه السوريه مفرده
العربيه عبد القادر خربوش اهلا بك عبد
القادر المعلومات المتوفره لديك تفضل
مرحبا ميسون انتقلنا من حركات الى منطقه
او قريه جسر الحديد هذه القريه التي
انتشرت صور عجيبه عنها وراينا الان لاحقها
من ادرار جراء هذا الزلزال حيث فصلها الى
نصفين اضرار جسيمه جدا
هذا المكان حيث اقف كان قبل الزلزال كان
طريقا وكان هناك مباني في هذا الجانب
ومباني في هذا الجانب لا يزال هذا
المستوصف صامدا في حين انفصلت انفصل كل
هذا الجزء عن مكانه وانهارت حوالي عشر
بنايات في الجهه المقابله في حين نزلت
ارضيه هذا المكان باكثر من ثلاثه امتار
حسب ما نقدره الان وايضا المباني كلها
يعني انجرفت حوالي 30 مترا في الجهه
المقابله حيث يوجد نهر وحسب روايات للسكان
الذين يقطنون في هذه المناطق سنحاول معرفه
كيف عاشوا هذا الحدث
لا ادري هل نجا منهم احد مرحبا مرحبا هل
في ناجين هون يعني نجذب
وفيات مثلا الحمد لله الحمد لله كان شكل
القريه قبل ما يعني كان الارض مستوي يعني
تسع بيوت كانوا هون كله راحوا تحت الاذرع
هذا الشق هذا انتم كنتم بالقرب من من نهر
كان فيه انجرافات سابقه للتربه ولا لا لا
ما فيش ما في شيء كان النهر والبيوت 30
متر فيهم وراحوا بين المي يعني
طلع على سلامتكم اذا هذه واحده من المشاهد
من قريه الى اخرى ومن حي الى اخر لكن
المشهد هنا قاسي نوعا ما ومخيف الى درجه
ان يبدو ان خط صدى زلزالي هذا هذا جزء منه
لانه قبل ان نصل الى هذا المكان لاحظنا
عند الطريق اضرار جسيمه طالت الطريق الذي
يربط هذه القريه
بمدينه انطاكيا مركز هاتاي ونحن لا نبعد
كثيرا عن الحدود السوريه وكما لاحظنا ايضا
على طول امتداد الارضيات هناك انه هناك
انجرافات كبيره وحفر تشكلت جراء هذا
الزلزال فيما يتعلق بالزلزال الذي ضرب
اليوم مدينه انطاليا
الاعداد اعداد الضحايا لم يعني يرتفع هناك
وفاه حاله وفاه واحده في حين اعداد
الاصابات تجاوزت المئه ولا تزال عمليات
البحث تحت خمسه مباني المزيد خلال نشرات
اللاحقه شكرا جزيلا لك من طبعا من حدود
التركيه السوريه موفد العربيه عبد القادر
خربوش شكرا جزيلا لك
ذكرت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان شركه تويتر
المملوكه للملياردير ايلون ماسك صرحت ما
لا يقل عن 200 موظف او حوالي 10% من قوتها
العامله في احدث جوله لتخفيض العماله منذ
ان تولى ماسك رئاسه شبكه التواصل
الاجتماعي الشهيره في اواخر اكتوبر العام
الماضي
في الجوله الاخيره من تخفيضات الوظائف
تويتر يستغني عن 200 موظف اي نحو 10% من
قرابه الفين موظف يعملون بالشركه عندما
استحوذ ايلون ماسك على تويتر في اكتوبر
الماضي كانت القوه العامله
7500 شخص لكن سريعا ما سعى ماسك الى خفض
التكاليف وبالطبع كانت سياسه الاستغناء عن
الموظفين الحل السحري
بحسب مصادر مطلعه لنيويورك تايمز جوله
التسريح الاخيره شملت مدير انتاج وخبراء
في مجال البيانات بالاضافه الى مهندسين
يعملون لتطوير ودعم تكنولوجيا التعليم
الالكتروني
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
زعيم كوريا الشماليه يتراس اجتماعا مفاجئا
وازمه للغذاء تلوح في الافق
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل من
ايران فعلى واقع الاحتجاجات المستمره في
زهدان اعلن القائد العام لشرطه ايران احمد
رضا رادان تعيين دوست علي جليليان قائدا
جديدا لشرطه محافظه بلوشيستان لحل مكان
محمد قمبري الذي عين قبل حوالي ثلاثه اشهر
فقط كما هدد قائد شرطه ايران البلوش
المحتجين بقوله لا نتهاون مع اي شخص عندما
يتعلق الامر بالامن ولن نسمح لاي شخص
بتجاوز الخط الاحمر
في المقابل زعما وزير خارجيه ايران حسين
امير عبد اللهيان ان بلاده واجهت اطرافا
ارهابيه وليست تظاهرات سلميه في الاشهر
الماضيه وفي كلمته امام مجلس حقوق الانسان
في برلين اتهمها عبد الله غربيه ناطقه
بالايرانيه بالترويج للعنف الاراضي
الايرانيه حسب تعبيره
هذا وقد كشفت وكشف موقع ايران انترناشونال
نقلا عن مصادر مقربه من القياديين في
الحركه الخضراء الايرانيه ميرسين موسوي
وزوجته زهراء
رهن كشفت وكشفت الموقع عن تجديد قيود
الاقامه الجبريه عليهما في ضوء انتقادات
وجهات للنظام المصادر ذكرت ان القرار جاء
بعدما نشر مسوي وزوجته بيانات مؤيده
للاحتجاجات الشعبيه في ايران كان امير
حسين موسوي قد دعى الى اجراء استفتاء حرفي
ايران وصياغه دستور جديد الامر الذي رحب
به ناشطون سياسيون واعلاميون معظمهم من
المقيمين في ايران من جهتها وصفت زوجته
زوجه تامر حسين موسى وعنف النظام الايراني
ضد المراه بالوحشي وبان لا مثيل له حتى في
ديكتاتوريات العصور الوسطى على حد تعبيرها
هذا وبالتزامن مع الاضطرابات الواسعه في
سوق العمله الايرانيه حصل البنك المركزي
على صلاحيات جديده للتدخل على امل طبعا
تحسين الوضع وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه قالت
ان البنك المركزي وفر الامكانيه لعرض
العملات الصعبه في اسواق التداول من قبل
البنوك الحكوميه ومؤسسات الصرافه التابعه
لها وكذلك محل الصرافه هبطت العمله
الايرانيه الى ادنى مستوى امام الدولار في
السوق غير الرسميه امس في وقت تتصاعد فيه
الاحتجاجات العماليه تمديدا بالاوضاع
المعيشيه المترديه بالتزامن مع ارتفاع نسب
التضخم
مشاهدينا الى كلمه هلا تويجري وهي رئيسه
جمعيه حقوق الانسان السعوديه في جنيف الى
هناك
انخفاضا كبيرا من 11.6 بالمئه الى 5.8 كما
صدرت السياسه الوطنيه لتشجيع تكافؤ الفرص
والمساواه في المعامله في الاستخدام
والمهنه والتي تهدف للقضاء على اي تمييز
في هذا المجال وفي مجال الحق في السكن فقد
ارتفعت نسبه تملك المواطنين المساكن من
47% في عام 2017 الى اكثر من 60% وبالنسبه
للحق في بيئه سليمه فان المملكه ملتزمه
بمواجهه التحديات المتزايده للتغير
المناخي وفي هذا الاطار فقد تم اطلاق
مبادرتي الصعود السعوديه الخضراء والشرق
الاوسط الاخضر ضمن سعي المملكه لتعزيز
شراكتها اقليميا ودوليا في مواجهه
التحديات والتغلب عليها وقد اعلنت المملكه
عن الاسهام بمبلغ مليارين و500 مليون
دولار دعما لمشروعات المبادره وميزانيه
استضافه الامان العامه على مدى العشر
سنوات القادمه
السيدات والساده
حققت المملكه خلال السنوات الاخيره تقدما
كبيرا في مجال تمكين المراه حيث تم اعتماد
هدف استراتيجي لرؤيه المملكه 2030 لزياده
نسبه مشاركتها في سوق العمل وقد تم انشاء
مركز تحقيق التوازن بين الجنسين عام 2021
ونتيجه لهذه الجهود ارتفعت حصه المراه في
سوق العمل خلال الفتره من 2017 حتى 2022
من 21.2% الى
34.7% وزاد معدل مشاركتها الاقتصاديه خلال
الفتره ذاتها من 17 الى 37 بالمئه كما
ارتفعت نسبه تمثيل المراه في المناصب
الاداريه العليا والمتوسطه خلال الفتره من
2017 الى 2021 من
28.6% الى 39%
السيدات والساده من منطلق اهتمام المملكه
بالحق في التعليم فقد تجاوزت جهودها
الاطار الوطني وصولا الى دعم هذا الحق على
المستوى الاقليمي والدولي ايمانا منها
بالدور الجوهري للتعليم في النهوض
بالانسان وتحقيق تطلعاته الى حياه كريمه
حيث قدمت مساعدات تنمويه وانسانيه للعديد
من الدول بلغت اكثر من ثلاث مليارات دولار
كما عملت حكومه بلادي على تعزيز الامن
الغذائي عالميا من خلال تقديمها مساعدات
بلغت ما يقارب 3 مليارات دولار وانطلاقا
من حرص حكومه بلادي على الوقوف الى جانب
المتضررين من ابناء الشعبين السوري
والتركي والتخفيف من اثار الزلزال المدمر
الذي تسبب في خسائر فادحه في الارواح
والممتلكات فقد وجه خادم الحرمين الشريفين
بتسيير جسر جوي لتقديم مساعدات صحيه
وايوائيه وغذائيه ولوجستيه وتنظيم حمله
شعبيه لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال وقد بلغ
اجمالي المساعدات حتى هذه اللحظه اكثر
مليون دولار وتاكيدا لدعم حكومه بلادي
لامن واستقرار اليمن ووقوفها مع الشعب
اليمني الشقيق فقد قدمت مساعدات اغاثيه
وانسانيه للاشقاء في اليمن بمبلغ يزيد على
عشر مليارات دولار اضافه الى ما يقوم به
البرنامج السعودي للتنميه واعمار اليمن من
مشاريع ومبادرات تنمويه بلغت ما يقارب
مليار دولار
السيدات والساده انطلاقا من قيام المملكه
الراسخه ودورها الريادي وسعها لارساء
الامن والسلم الدوليين وتعزيز حقوق
الانسان فانها لم تدخر جهدا في دعم
القضايا الانسانيه ومن ذلك ابداء المملكه
استعدادها للوساطه بحل الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه فضلا عن اسهام وساطه صاحب
السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ولي العهد ورئيس مجلس الوزراء في
اطلاق سراح العديد من الاسرى وعودتهم الى
بلدانهم وفيما يتعلق بقرار حكومه تصريف
الاعمال الافغانيه بمنع الفتيات
الافغانيات من التعليم الجامعي فان حكومه
بلادي تبدي اسفها الشديد لهذا القرار
وتدعوها للتراجع عنه لتمكين المراه من
التمتع بكامل حقوقها دون تمييز كما تعرب
حكومه بلادي عن ادانتها واستنكارها لقيام
عدد من المتطرفين باحراق وتنسيق نسخ من
المصحف الشريف في عدد من الدول الاوروبيه
وتؤكد على ضروره التقيد بالمباد الاحكام
التي نصت عليها المعايير الدوليه لحقوق
الانسان والتي تحضر اي دعوه للكراهيه
القوميه او العنصريه او الدينيه تشكل
تحريضا على التمييز او العداوه او العنف
ختاما السيدات والساده تؤكد حكومه بلادي
عزمها على مواصله تعزيز وحمايه حقوق
الانسان انطلاقا من قيامها الراسخه واراده
قيادتها التي تقدم الانسان على كل اعتبار
كما تؤكد على اهميه احترام التنوع الثقافي
والمساواه بين الشعوب في ضوء الصكوك
والمواثيق الدوليه وتدعو حكومه بلادي مجلس
حقوق الانسان الى القيام بمسؤولياته تجاه
تحسين اوضاع حقوق الانسان في العالم في جو
من الحوار البناء والالتزام بالشفافيه
والموضوعيه وتعزيز ثقافه التسامح كما تؤكد
حكومه بلادي على ضروره ضروره اعطاء جميع
حقوق الانسان القدر ذاته من الاهتمام بحيث
لا يتم التركيز على حقوق على حساب اخرى
اعمالا لمبدا تكامليه حقوق الانسان وعدم
قابليتها للتجزئه شكرا لكم على حسن
استماعكم والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اذا مشاهدينا كانت هذه كلمه السعوديه في
مجلس حقوق الانسان في جنيف اعلنت هيئه
الاذاعه البريطانيه التوصل الى اتفاق
النهائي بشان خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد
الاوروبي رويترز قالت انه تم حل المسائل
العالقه بوضع التجاره في جزيره ايرلندا
بين ايرلندا الشماليه التابعه لبريطانيا
وجمهوريه ايرلندا التابعه للاتحاد
الاوروبي قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي
سوناك انه سيعقد اجتماعا مع رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه مساء اليوم لاعلان
تفاصيل الاتفاق كانت رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه وصلت الى لندن صباح اليوم مؤكده
انها تتطلع الى بدء فصل جديد في العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه صفحه الخلافات مع المملكه
المتحده
المزيد معنا من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى
زارو اهلا بك مصطفى اي معلومات لدينا حول
ما تم التوصل اليه حتى الان
حقيقه ليست هناك تفاصيل لكن نتوقع ان يكشف
رئيس وزراء في ندوه صحفيه مع
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه عن هذا الاتفاق
الذي يعني يتطلب اشهر من المفاوضات وهذه
ومجؤها الى بريطانيا هو تاكيد على ان هذا
الاتفاق كان وشيكا بالرغم من بعض التردد
من بعض اعضاء يعني حزب المحافظين وخاصه
الحزب الوحدوي الذي شرط تجاوز يعني عقبات
لتقبل هكذا اتفاق لكن ما كان تم الترويج
له يعني حقيقه اصبح واقعا الان وسنتعرف عن
المزيد وخاصه وان هذا الاتفاق هو خاص فقط
بقواعد التجاره بين
بريطانيا اي الاقاليم الذي تتكون منها س
من انجلترا او ويلز او اسكتلندا باتجاه
ايرلندا الشماليه والعكس ايضا اذا ما كانت
هذه البضائع يعني تنتهي او يتم استخدامها
او استهلاكها في الرانده الشماليه يجب
التذكير بان الاتفاق
ايراندا الشماليه يقضي بان تكون هناك
قواعد اوروبيه تتبعها ايرلندا الشماليه
للحفاظ على حدود بريه يعني
ليست هناك حدود بريه بسبب بسبب الاتفاق
السلام الذي تم التوقيع عليه عام 98
وبالتالي كان يجب يعني اعطاء بعض
الاجراءات للاتحاد الاوروبي حتى يستطيع
التحكم في كل البضائع التي تصل
في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي ننتظر المؤتمر
الصحفي لنعرف التفاصيل مصطفى زارو مراسل
العربيه من لندن شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المعلومات
افتتح زعيم كوريا الشماليه اجتماعا للجنه
المركزيه لحزبه لمناقشه التنميه الزراعيه
في ظل تقارير عن نقص خطير في الغذاء عاده
ما تعقد مثل هذه الاجتماعات مره او مرتين
في السنه لكن هذا الاجتماع ياتي بعد شهرين
فقط من الاجتماع السابق نتابع
ازمه غذاء في كوريا الشماليه تلوح في
الافق بينما تمضي بيونغي قدوما في
برنامجها الصاروخي
اضطره زعيم وكوريا الشماليه لاعاده ترتيب
اولوياته بعقد اجتماع لمناقشه التنميه
الزراعيه لتجنب حدوث مجاعه في البلاد عاده
ما يعقد مثل هذا الاجتماع مره او مرتين في
السنه لكن هذه المره جاء بعد شهرين فقط من
سابقه ما اثار تكهنات عن نقص خطير محتمل
في الغذاء
مراجعه برنامج الثوره الريفيه في العصر
الجديد احتل المرتبه الاولى لاهم مواضيع
طاوله المناقشه لدى كيم جونغ اون اما في
شمالك يونج فالوقت ينفذ اذ افاد التقارير
بسقوط ضحايا جراء سوء التغذيه تواجه كوريا
الشماليه صعوبات منذ فتره طويله في توفير
الغذاء جراء العقوبات الغربيه بسبب
برنامجها الصاروخي حيث باتت اكثر تاثرا
بشده الكوارث الطبيعيه بما في ذلك
الفيضانات الجفاف
[موسيقى]
وصلنا الى نهايه الخامسه لمتابعه ملفات
العربيه المزيد من الاخبار وايضا
التحليلات على موقعنا العربيه نت رجاء مسح
الكود الذي نتامل ان يظهر على الشاشه مش
راح ظهر على الشاشه شكرا للمتابعه
مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]